- Well, hello everyone,
and welcome to the second
installment of the webinar series
Doing Chinese History in a New Era.
This series is organized by
Denise Ho at Yale University
and myself, Emily Baum, at UC Irvine.
And it began last summer in
response to the persistent
and in some ways unprecedented challenges
that have been facing
researchers and scholars
in the Chinese studies field.
So, this series has been
generously sponsored
by the Council on East Asian
Studies at Yale University
and Long U.S.-China
Institute at UC Irvine.
We are also very grateful to
our long list of co-sponsors,
and if you'll just bear
with me for a second,
I'm gonna read through
them really quickly.
Harvard University's Fairbank Center,
the Center for East Asian
Studies at Stanford University,
The project on China's Global Sharp Power
at the Hoover Institution at Stanford,
the Center for Asian
Research at York University,
the Department of History
at Simon Fraser university,
the Institute of Asian Research
at the University of British Columbia,
the East Asian Studies program
at Johns Hopkins University,
the East Asian Studies
program at UC Santa Cruz,
the Global China Center
at Hong Kong University
of Science and Technology,
and the Hong Kong Institute
for the Humanities and Social Sciences
at the University of Hong Kong.
So in this session, we will
be focusing on the subject
of pivoting to a new research topic.
Many of us, myself included,
have had to dramatically
change or rethink the content
and scope of our research
in the face of challenges imposed
by COVID-19, archival closures,
or simply increasing restrictions
on travel and free speech.
To address some of these issues,
we have invited four speakers
who are either completing
or who have recently completed
a thesis or dissertation,
and who have had to adapt their topics
because of changing research conditions.
They are going to speak
about their experiences
and hopefully offer
some advice and guidance
for those of us who are
facing similar circumstances.
So, each presenter will speak
for approximately 10 minutes,
and at the end of the session
we will reconvene for a moderated Q&A.
If you have a question at any point,
and you don't necessarily have
to wait for the Q&A session,
but please feel free to ask your question
using the Q&A button at
the bottom of your screen.
In total, this webinar should last
for approximately 75 minutes,
just to give you a heads up,
and it will be recorded
in case you can't stay until the end.
We will send out a link
to the YouTube video
in a follow-up email to all
registered participants.
So, let us go ahead and get started.
Speaking first will be Michael Collins.
Michael is a researcher
focusing on China's global
governance initiatives.
He was a research associate
at the Council on Foreign Relations,
and before that he received
his MA in Chinese history
from Peking University's Yenching Academy.
So, I will turn it over
to you now, Michael.
- Thanks so much.
Let me share my screen.
Great.
So I guess the theme of my presentation
is Researching Chinese History:
Flexibility and Creativity.
So to start,
my original idea was...
Or I began researching
on my master's thesis
in the fall of 2018.
At the time, I was living on
Peking University's campus
as part of the Yenching Academy program.
I originally intended for my thesis
to focus on Chinese anarchists
at the turn of the 20th century.
I wanted to show that
rather than passively receiving anarchism
from Western sources, whether
it was in Paris or Japan,
Chinese anarchists were
playing a very active role,
and even leading
the East Asian anarchist movement
that was occurring at this period.
To do this, I wanted to map
out Chinese anarchist networks
to demonstrate their
centrality to other East
and Southeast Asian anarchist movements,
particularly in Korea and Vietnam.
And I was really inspired to do this
by a few different sources,
but particularly by a book by
Arif Dirlik and Ming K. Chan
that focused on Shanghai's
Labor University,
which had an abundance of
anarchists, not just from Asia,
but from all over the globe
who were working together
to try and think about how
to give both theoretical
and practical teaching to anarchists,
a growing cohort of anarchists in China.
To do this research, I was
planning on using archives
at PKU and Fudan,
as well as some libraries
in the US and the UK.
I also expected to be able to travel
particularly to Northeast
provinces of China
where there was a great number
of archives that were open
to look at cooperation between
North Korean anarchists
and American or and Chinese anarchists.
So, pretty quickly on
in the research process
I encountered both bureaucratic hurdles,
which I expected, but
also political hurdles
that prevented me from accessing archives,
archives which had previously
given me agreements
to access certain materials
came up with reasons why I
could no longer see them,
and reasons that my
classmates were not facing.
And heightened political sensitivities
around Chinese anarchists,
especially as kind of some
big historical anniversaries
were coming up in China
really tightened the access to archives,
even at PKU, which was
surprising given my affiliation.
And then, once COVID
became an issue in
China and then globally,
and as US-China ties
really soured and fell out,
my ability to access any archives in China
were pretty closed as
I relocated to the US.
And so, as I was
kind of reformulating my plan,
I took a moment to kind of
mourn the loss of the topic.
And once I had kind of picked myself up
and gotten back in the race,
I discussed with my thesis advisor
what would be feasible,
and he really encouraged me
to kind of not give up on the topic,
but just widen the aperture
of what I was studying
and to return to my
original literature review
to see if I could find
questions that would answer
the same question,
or give answers that I
was still interested in,
but would have materials that
I could get access to easily
and in a timely manner.
I also assessed what was feasible
given COVID restrictions,
and at the time we really didn't know
when archives would reopen,
and so I just kind of assumed
that I would not be able to
go in-person to any archives
before my thesis was due for defense.
And so, I really focused
on archival materials
in the US and the UK,
particularly resources
that had extensive digitized collections.
And also I reached out to a
number of scholars in the field,
people whose books I was referencing,
scholars I had met at conferences
to not only ask their advice,
but also to see if they
had primary sources
that I was looking for perhaps digitized
on their own computer
or in their own records.
And so for the new topic,
as I was doing this review
a few weeks into it,
I noticed a relative
lack of scholarly work
on Chinese anarchists in America,
particularly by historians
of America's labor movements
and America's anarchist movements.
And I, at the same time,
I noticed a relative abundance
of primary source materials
which told a story that I was
intrigued to look into more,
and really gave me the feeling
that there was a lot more out there
that I could uncover through the research.
So, I shifted gears a bit and
I focused my research topic
on anarchist groups started by
Chinese immigrants in America
and examined their participation
in and oftentimes their exclusion from
early 20th American labor
and anarchist movements.
And as a native of the Bay Area,
I was particularly
focused on San Francisco,
which had a very vibrant
Chinese immigrant community
and a very politically
active immigrant community.
For this research, I am
deeply, deeply indebted
to the work of kind of
the master archivist
Him Mark Lai and the Berkeley
University Libraries,
which have fantastic collections,
a lot of which are digitized,
which really enabled
me to do this research.
And so, kind of over the
year and a half long process
of this research,
I've collected a number of resources
and thought about a few pieces of advice
that I hope are very useful.
And I can kind of go in a bit
to what I found the strengths
of these sources were,
as well as kind of where
they might be lacking.
And so, for the first four
that I have listed under the resources,
all of these were fantastic
for accessing old publications,
newspapers, anarchist magazines,
books that are no longer in circulation
or that are hard to come by.
But especially with the
first listed source,
I found that the search
terms you have to use,
or the process for finding materials
is not the most straightforward.
Oftentimes, materials are not categorized
by their name or by their subject,
and so you really have
to search far afield
to find what you're looking for,
but once you find it,
they're usually free to access,
free to download, and
are incredibly helpful.
And then the last two are a bit more niche
for people that are interested
in anarchist's movements,
whether they're in the
US or somewhere else.
But I found that the
online Anarchist Library
and the Kate Sharpley Library
were fantastic for kind of giving me
both a general picture of the landscape,
but also for finding sources
that I didn't even know were out there.
And they have dedicated
teams that curate the content
and are happy to answer questions
or provide advice for you.
And then in terms of advice,
the main thing that I
was told by my advisor
and I highly recommend was read broadly
because I felt pressure initially
to really decide on a topic,
and once I'd found it to
kind of dig down quickly
and kind of get to the work of writing.
But when I stepped back,
I realized that a lot of
the books that I'd read,
whether they were at undergrad
or through the course
of my master's program,
had tidbits of information or
sources that I found useful
once I went back to
re-write and re-research.
Secondly, think creatively
and re-evaluate.
And so for me, I went
from going from a more,
I would say, descriptive thesis topic
to one which was more
focused on historiography
and trying to kind of
fill in the narrative
of both the American labor
and anarchist movements,
and Chinese immigrant stories in the US.
Next, I found it very
helpful to look broadly
through anthologies and appendices
because oftentimes there's kind
of hidden gems within there
that pointed me in the right direction.
And then for the last,
the next two are related,
but contact scholars and librarians,
whether it's over Twitter,
LinkedIn, ScholarNet,
and lean on your peers and wider network
because I found that by discussing
my topic with my cohort,
they were often able to
point me to a bookstore
in Manchester that had some of the sources
I was looking for.
Or at one point we were going
through somebody's garage
who had these boxes from a library
that they used to curate,
which has since closed.
And then finally, I would say
to just adjust expectations,
I was, as I said, very
disappointed at the outset,
but once I kind of got through
the initial grief of the loss,
I was really happy with the process
and was able to produce something
that I was very proud to defend.
So, thank you so much,
And I look forward to your questions.
- Great, thank you so much, Michael.
Up next will be Bill Figueroa.
Dr. Figueroa completed his PhD
at the University of Pennsylvania,
and he is currently a postdoctoral fellow
at the University of
Pennsylvania Middle East Center.
So, Bill, go ahead.
- Okay, great.
Well, thank you for that introduction.
I don't have a fancy PowerPoint,
but I'm just gonna try to just
share some of my experiences.
So, the title of the workshop is you know,
Pivoting to a New Research Topic,
and that's something I've
had to do a few times
through the process of finishing my PhD.
And I'm really glad to
have the opportunity
to share my experiences with you all,
so thanks to Emily and to everyone else
who put the work in to put this together.
My dissertation ended up
changing substantially
from how I originally conceived it
in part due to problems
in how I was framing it,
and in part due to lack of
access to archival sources.
Even after I made a lot of these changes,
I had to finish the writing
process during the pandemic,
which also limited my ability
to track down new sources
or to revisit archives
as new questions came up,
but it also presented
some new opportunities
so I'm gonna try to kind of
take you through that process
going throughout this presentation.
After going through all that,
I do think I have some
thoughts I can share
about how to be flexible with your topic,
and in your approach to
what sources you can use
and what kind of things
you can do with them.
So, when I started graduate school,
I had it in my mind that
I really wanted to study
the history of Sino-Iranian relations,
you know, the relationship
between China and Iran.
I had been studying Chinese history
and Chinese language as an
undergraduate for my masters.
And during my PhD,
I branched out to middle Eastern history,
and especially the history of Iran
and started studying Persian.
You know, my goal was after
looking at the research
that had been done, it
was really clear to me
that most of it had been done by people
either coming, you know,
primarily coming from the China side
and a bit coming from the Iran side.
And most people had only
really looked at sources
from one language or another,
and then otherwise been
relying on secondary sources
or works in English for everything else.
So, you know, as I was
going through the literature
that had been done on the subject,
it wasn't long before
I came across anecdotes
about the popularity of Maoism
as a political orientation
amongst Iranian student radicals
in the 1960s.
I was really intrigued by
the idea of Iranian Maoism,
which seemed to demand an explanation
and has been largely overlooked.
And at least according to me,
underappreciated by historians
of both Chinese and Iranian history.
So, my original dissertation
topic was on just that,
it was on Iranian Maoism, its history,
its particular, you know,
the particular activities
of a specific Maoist organizations,
Sazman-e Enghelabi,
which was a branch of the
main Iranian communist party,
the Tudeh Party,
and was run by dissident
students in Europe.
So Sazman-e Enghelabi,
which means the
revolutionary organization,
as in like the revolutionary
faction of the Tudeh Party
was a major force amongst
Iranian student politics
in both Europe and the
US in the 60s and 70s.
And I wanted to write
something like a thick history
of their organization,
them as a social movement and their impact
on Iranian history as I charted out.
You know, and part of the
problem that I first encountered
was that this was a pretty
brief moment in history.
You know, it was like mostly
their influenced peaked
from the late 60s to the early 70s,
but I still really wanted
I was drawn to the story.
Most intriguingly to me,
the group had ties to
the Chinese government
and then traveled to
China for revolutionary
and ideological training,
they seem to play a part in
China's international propaganda
efforts during the Cultural Revolution.
And to me, you know,
the story of these like
would-be revolutionaries
was just honestly really cool,
It was the first thing
that I had discovered
that I was like this is something
that people don't know
about that I can write about
that excites me in a
way, it was interesting,
it was new, I didn't quite
fully understand it at first.
They had really cool, you know,
just sort of speeches and
pamphlets that they had put out,
just kind of like really
fascinating rhetoric
and I wanted to understand
where it was coming from,
how you had this kind of fusion
or cross fertilization of interests
of Islamists and radical
communists at the same time.
So, you know, I was well
maybe a little bit dazzled
by the idea and it was and as a result
I ended up focusing pretty narrowly
on this topic alone at first,
and that was probably my first mistake.
You know, it's good to keep an open mind
on the broader picture.
So, you know, once I came
back down to earth about it,
I ran into two problems right away.
First was the problem of sources,
I couldn't access anything
official about this group.
Chinese archives as Michael
mentioned during this period
2018 were reportedly, I didn't
get a chance to go and try,
but from what I'd heard, they
were not open to researchers.
And in any event I had
been told by another,
by a friend who had had
a personal interest,
you know, one of the people
I ended up interviewing
that they had tried and
failed a couple of years ago
to access holdings related
to Sazman Enghelabi
at the Foreign Ministry
Archives in Beijing.
So I didn't think I was
gonna be any more successful
than they were,
they kind of had more of
an even direct connection
than I did.
The subject is also a little sensitive
in light of modern Sino-Iranian relations,
and the official views of
the CCP on its malice past.
I have actually been angrily
berated by party members
from a Chinese university
before at a conference
over just some objections they had
to the way I portrayed
Maoism as an ideology.
So, you know, whenever you're
working on subjects like this,
it can be difficult to access archives.
Researching in Iran is
similarly difficult,
you know, I think probably people,
anyone who follows the
news understands that,
you know, it's both not feasible
and not safe for Americans to do research
on sensitive subjects in Iran,
so I didn't really wanna
go down that route.
The best bet for me was to interview
some of the participants
because they were still around,
some of them lived in Europe
and the United States,
but that required some networking
and interviews in Persian,
and my language skills were just,
they weren't quite up
to the task just yet.
You know, I could read,
but I wasn't quite ready to
conduct full-on interviews
and get the answers that I needed.
Secondly, my primary advisor,
Firoozeh Kashani-Sabet,
who I am really indebted for,
for both the direction and the quality
I think of the dissertation
I produced in the end.
She pointed out that Iranian Maoism
was at the end of the day a fascinating
but very narrow topic.
It was a niche interest
within a subfield of Iranian studies,
mostly amongst historians
of the Iranian left.
It would probably grab,
you know, attract some
attention within China studies,
but Julia Lovell hadn't
written her book yet
"Global Maoism", so there
wasn't as much attention
that idea as there is right now.
It also only covered, as I
said, a short period of time,
and while I was excited about
this idea of a deep dive,
she encouraged me to
think bigger and broader.
I needed to adjust my topic
so that I'd be able to attract
the interest of a wide
variety of historians,
both within and without my subfield
in order to avoid pigeonholing myself
and to maximize my
chances on the job market.
I mean, these are serious
things we have to think about.
And, you know, being a historian
of both Iran and China,
I really wanted to avoid having
to lean too hard to one side
and to find myself in a position
where I wasn't appealing to a broad enough
cross section of people to be successful
as someone who's not yet
either entirely Chinese
or entirely Middle East
studies when applying for jobs
in the China and Middle
East studies fields.
So basically, I reworked my
project from the ground up
and instead of focusing
narrowly on Iranian Maoism,
I decided to carve out a bit
of a larger space for myself.
I noted that all, or nearly all studies
of Sino-Iranian history
started around 1972,
and focus on events after 1979.
I strongly suspected for
my background reading
and from the few scraps of
sources I had come across
that there were substantial connections
in earlier periods as well.
So, I set out to write a survey
of Sino-Iranian relations
from the constitutional period
to these Islamic Revolution
from 1905 to 1979,
tracing different moments of
both official and unofficial
Sino-Iranian interactions
from the constitutional period
to interactions between nationalist China
under Chiang Kai-shek
and the early nationalist
government of Reza Khan/Reza Shah in Iran,
and then moving into his
sort of Cold War politics
of the 1950s and 1960s.
You know, this is a lot broader
and I was able to keep Iranian
Maoism as a chapter later on,
and it freed me up to find
new topics to focus on
for the earlier period.
You know, at first glance you would think
that this would actually
make it harder to study
given the lack of sources,
but it actually ended up giving
me a lot more to work with.
Once I realized that there
were resources I could use
outside of archives,
especially for those of you
working on the late 19th,
early 20th centuries,
newspapers, travelogs, memoirs
are an incredible source
for day to day events that
have gone undocumented
by historians, especially for those of you
who are looking to do something similar,
you know, to Sino-Iranian relations
perhaps to look at another
less commonly explored aspect
of China's foreign policy
or relations with the rest of the world.
I mean, everyone's doing global
history right now, right?
That's what we're all supposed to do.
You know, telegraphs allowed
people from all over the world
during this time to discuss and
learn about foreign affairs.
And I found newspaper records
of Iranian constitutionalists
discussing China,
Chinese constitutionalist
inspired by Persia,
Iranian diplomats in Shanghai,
Chinese merchants petitioning
the Republican government
for a trade agreement with Iran,
Iranian editorials on Chiang Kai-shek.
I mean, it was really just a lot
of different things I found.
So, I think my first tip is
really just keep an open mind
about where you can find your sources
and what constitutes a
useful source to you.
It's especially relevant
for Chinese history
because Chinese newspapers
are readily available in digital form.
There is a number of
archives that you can access
through a university subscription
if you're at a school
that supports research
into Chinese history,
there's a good chance
your library has them,
that's how I've always accessed them.
Through this, you can find
Chinese and English language
newspapers from and published in China
from the late 19th century
to the 20th century.
For me, that's been an
absolute treasure trove
of sources about events that,
you know, otherwise
I'd have no idea about.
And they can be searched
very easily in digital form,
which makes things a lot easier.
It's also true about Persian newspapers,
although they're less readily digitized.
Travelogs are also a
great thing to hunt down,
you have surprising amounts of information
buried in travelogs about
day to day activities
of people in different places.
Some things I did find in
archives like pamphlets,
propaganda posters,
there's a lot of material
related to this stuff
if you are interested at
the International Institute
of Social History in Amsterdam,
the Hoover Institute in California,
where I got to do some research.
Oh, you do need to be able to read Persian
for the most part,
they do have a couple of
things in English as well.
When I was there, I did make,
I made it a habit of going for
kind of brief archival trips
and digitizing as much
as I could on my own
while I was there and taking
it home to read later.
And it's a really good thing I did that
because shortly after I
got back from the archives
and set to writing, the pandemic hit.
So, you know, at first that
made things a lot more difficult
because or at least in theory
because I couldn't go
to any other archives,
as I said, as questions came up.
But in some ways it did kind of end up
being a blessing in disguise
other than the obvious fact
that there was literally nothing
else to do except work on my dissertation,
(laughs) which may have
been a larger factor
in me actually completing
it than I'd like to admit.
There was also the fact
that even more sources
were being digitized and made accessible
due to the pandemic.
I also turned to networking, social media,
I learned about this opportunity
from Twitter (laughs).
So, you know, that's actually
been a surprisingly good
source of not just
information and networking,
but also just people who
have a personal interest
in the things that you're studying,
who might be able to supply
you with surprising sources.
Also just reaching out to scholars
I met at virtual conferences
or who seemed like they will
be interested in my work.
Virtual conferences made
it really easy to meet
and develop relationships with colleagues
in Iran and China in particular.
And some of my most interesting finds
have come from a Chinese student,
who's studying at University
of Tehran that I met,
who has access to a lot of materials
that I just wouldn't otherwise
be able to get myself.
So most of these things like digitization
and virtual conferences,
they're not going anywhere even
after the pandemic is over,
they're definitely gonna stick around
so you can still take advantage of that.
My time is definitely
up, so just to summarize,
try to think broadly,
be flexible in what
kinds of sources you use,
don't be afraid to open up your topic
and try to break completely new ground
because if your research succeeds in that,
it'll be that much more valuable.
Make good use of digital
sources, work with what you have,
virtual conferences are
a great way to network.
And of course, reach out
to scholars in your fields
who might be interested in
your work, read their work.
A lot of the ideas that I came up with
for how to frame my ideas came
from reading other scholars,
Reem Abou-El-Fadl especially,
I'm very indebted to her
work on foreign relations,
and talk to them and talk to your advisor
about how to frame your topic.
You know, senior scholars
will often see things
and issues that you might miss
because you're not as deeply embedded
in the field as they are.
So, thank you very much,
and I hope you guys enjoyed my rambling.
- Great, thank you so much, Bill.
I've already started to see a
couple of overlapping themes
between your presentation
and Michael's presentation,
the need to read broadly, to network,
to reach out to other scholars,
and to also just be on
the constant lookout
for new digitized sources,
which seems to be proliferating every day.
Okay, so speaking next will be Yi Ci Lo.
Yi Ci is currently finishing
up her dissertation
at UC Irvine,
and in the fall she'll
become a post-doctoral fellow
at the Schwarzman Center
at Tsinghua University in Beijing.
So, go ahead, Yi Ci.
- Great, thank you.
So, good evening,
afternoon, morning everyone.
My name is Yi Ci and I am
finishing my dissertation
at the University of California Irvine.
So, thanks Professors
Emily Baum and Denise Ho
for organizing this webinar.
I'm right at the tail end of grad school,
so it feels like a good moment
to be reflecting on the twists and turns
of my research journey.
And hopefully, it's
something that'll be helpful
for grad students who are
just beginning to grapple
with dissertation research
in these challenging circumstances.
So, I'm going to try
to share my screen now.
My original project was a study
about the early history
of blood transfusion
and blood banking in 20th century China.
One of my tentative titles
was Unnatural Circulations:
Blood Transfusion and
Banking in Modern China.
I proposed to track changing medical
and cultural definitions of blood
as the practices of blood transfusion,
and then blood banking were introduced
and then gradually normalized
across the 20th century.
This process started
early in the 20th century
when biomedical doctors
came up with tables,
that you can see here,
explaining basic facts about
blood types in transfusion.
Like people in other places,
people in China were initially suspicious
and they were fearful about
moving blood between bodies.
But some of the consternation
also came from very culturally
specific understandings
of blood as (indistinct),
and as something that was
connected to bloodline descent.
I had hoped to untangle
the uneasy coexistence
of these multiple definitions of blood
as medical professionals
and political leaders
called on people to give blood.
Naturalizing blood donation
was a very long process
that stretched beyond the triumph
of the Chinese Communist Party in 1949.
In the People's Republic of China,
one of the key events I
was hoping to write about
was a large scale government-run
blood donation campaign
in the 1960s on the eve of
the Cultural Revolution,
just when there was a
rising tide of consciousness
about bloodline theory,
the idea that socialist
revolutionary credentials
could be passed down
through the bloodline.
So, that's what I proposed to do
when I hit never tried to
get into a Chinese archive
or tried to get people in Chinese archives
to give me access to documents
about the Cultural Revolution,
which I found out was not a simple request
when I tried to do these
things in 2018 and 2019.
The big problem really
was the post-1949 solstice.
When I went to conduct
pre-dissertation research in China,
it was obvious that
getting access to documents
about things that happen after 1949
was going to be a very big
problem for my project.
When I talked to people about my work,
I got the impression that
accessing the PRC documents,
especially documents that touched
on the Cultural Revolution
was going to be very
difficult to impossible.
And looking back, they were really right
to be quite discouraging
because when I did make it
into multiple Chinese archives,
I just couldn't get access to the sources
that I wanted to read
about blood transfusion
and blood donation in Mao's China.
At that point, of course,
I consider sort of stopping
my narrative at 1949
with the dissertation,
but ultimately I decided that
the development in the
PRC was so significant
and so integral to telling a full story
of how blood transfusion came to China,
that the project would be
fundamentally incomplete
if I stopped at 1949.
So given the constraints,
I returned to the archives
looking for any topic,
and eventually I stumbled
onto units of measurement
and metrological reform.
Measuring Up to Modernity
the title of my dissertation
tracks how the existence
of multiple systems
and practices of measurement in China
came to be perceived as a problem
by the late 19th century,
and how the Nanjing government
worked furiously to design
and then enforce a single
system of measurement
throughout China into
the 1930s and the 1940s.
So with this topic, the
arc kind of sits squarely
in the first half of the 20th century
so I dodged the post-1949 problem.
At the archives, I found
that when I asked people
for records about metrological
reform and administration,
they tended to be quite bemused.
And I have had more than
one person been so curious
that they had to ask me why I was reading
what I was reading,
but the important thing
is they always gave me the
files that I asked for.
And this was a drastically
different reaction
compared to when I went into archives
and asked for documents
related to blood transfusion
and banking in Mao's China.
In terms of sources like Bill,
I was I'm very fortunate
that there's a wealth
of published sources that
track official scientific,
popular and foreign thinking
about the state of measurement in China.
Once the Nanjing government
announced the reform
in 1928 and 29, it also published
a lot of public education
materials and instructions
about how to use the new
system of measurement.
Objections to and
disputes about the system
were also recorded and published
rather than archival sources,
so these are a lot of the
periodicals and newspapers
that were publish that at time.
And these sources allowed me
to examine the ways in which
different groups responded to
the government's insistence
that they all use a single
system of measurement.
And in fact, I have to say
that I had a lot of fun
working with these sources
because there was a variety of people
who were in fact, very
invested in measurement,
and they wrote very
passionately and heatedly
about metrological reform.
Measurement was also the kind of topic
I read in the margins of
many kinds of sources.
For instance, it was easy
for me to check the units
that people used when they
report economic information,
or when newspapers reported on
track and field competitions.
So, in all I could access
a very healthy pool
of published sources, which was a relief
because of how tight
archival access had become
since I started grad school
and dissertation research.
But in terms of archives,
I was able to work with the collections
at the second historical
archives in Nanjing.
And this was really
important archive for me
because of the topic
and because I was writing about
the Kuomintang's Nanjing-based regime.
I faced the usual challenges
that you would face
in a Chinese archive,
you know, I couldn't read certain files
that I wanted to read,
they wouldn't print certain
pages that I wanted printed.
But overall, I managed to
get a lot of key sources
about early internal
discussions when officials
were still designing the
system of measurement
in the 1910s and the 1920s.
And I also got some really great sources
about the really early days
of pushing this system
of measurement through
when they were trying to
figure out how they were going
to create the original standards
and to certify the authenticity
and the accuracy of the new standards
for China's weights and measures.
When my archival
researcher was interrupted
by the global pandemic,
I also went to two archives in Taipei,
the National Archives and
the Kuomintang Archives.
At the National Archives.
I was mainly able to get
sources about methodological
standardization when the
Kuomintang took the campaign
to Taiwan after 1945.
So, in that strange 1945-49 interregnum,
the Kuomintang told people in Taiwan
that they should abandon
Japanese units of measurement
and embrace Chinese weights and measures
because they were really Chinese
and they were now reunited
with the motherland.
The National Archives also
had a wealth of documents
about the difficulties of
enforcing the new system
of measurement in different parts
and different sectors in Taiwan.
So, it really gave me a new case study
of the difficulties and realities
of enforcing a new system of
measurement on the ground.
At the Kuomintang archives,
I found some records about
the early discussions
of metrological reform,
but also lots of interesting documents
about other sorts of standardizations,
which the Kuomintang tried to carry out
like getting people to
celebrate the New Year
on the 1st of January.
Looking back at the process,
I would say two things to
people who find themselves
in the position of doing research
in this particular source-scarce era.
I think it's important to keep looking,
especially where it's possible.
Of course, you have to keep
trying to get archival sources,
but in the meantime,
you really also have to look
at what's publicly accessible to you.
Personally, I've always found it fruitful
to check out like special collections
or the reading rooms
dedicated to modern history
at libraries in China.
I always find good public
education materials
about public health or popular
science from the 1930s,
50s, or 80s, which are all
good jumping off points for me.
I would also say that
at this particular time,
it makes a lot of sense to
look at the possibilities
in Taiwan, especially
the National Archives
since you can such it's database
to get a sense of whether
it would make sense
for you to go down to Taipei in-person
to work at this archive.
Second, I would say that,
you know, you really have to
keep reading with an open mind,
anything you get to read.
If you can't get the sources
you originally set out to find,
find something else and read that,
and be prepared to follow any source
that you find interesting
where it may lead you.
The hard truth is that you have to work
with the sources you can get,
you can't produce a dissertation
with sources can't get.
So, all the sauces you can get,
even if they're not about
the original topics,
you should read them because
you might not write this
as the dissertation,
you think that you envision writing,
but it might be a really great one anyway.
So, that's all I have for you today,
and hopefully that's what happened to me
in the last three years,
and I hope that it's a source of hope
and comfort to people rather than dismay.
And I look forward to
answering your questions later.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Yi Ci.
And I have to say just selfishly,
I hope that unnatural circulations
will become your second book,
even if it is not your first.
Okay, so last but not
least is Tullia Fraser.
Tullia recently completed
a master's degree
in museum and artifacts
studies at Durham University,
where she also did her BA in archeology.
She's currently a project associate
with the University Museum and Art Gallery
at the University of Hong Kong.
So, go ahead Tullia.
- Thank you for the kind introduction.
Today, I am delighted to be
talking about my experience
with my completing my MA
Museum and Artifacts Studies
at Durham University in the UK.
And I really wanted to do a topic
that was really personal
to my own background,
looking at basically how
the Chinese diasporas
were displayed in British museum spaces.
But at first, I actually
wanted to focus on Newcastle,
partly because I was based there,
I was connected there,
and I wanted to evaluate
a specific project called
Destination Tyneside,
which was the only museum
display that was permanent
in the UK on the topic of migration.
And it was informed by a really robust
public participation scheme.
So, it was really unique and
it was situated in a city
that had a long presence
of Chinese people.
So to that end,
I wanted to firstly review
historically the migration
from Hong Kong to Newcastle,
engaging with primary
resources and archives.
And I wanted to sit in the gallery
over a course of several
months with my field visits,
looking at maybe visitor observation
or even talking to them
to see what they're engaging
with, and what they're not.
And finally, I was really keen to talk
to actual members of the
Chinese community there,
talk about their life,
but also talk about if the
museum actually plays a role
in their sense of belonging
or placemaking in the area.
So, I pretty much hit the first hurdle
when the first national
lockdown was imposed in the UK,
archives and museums were closed,
there was a stay at home order,
and the Hong Kong government,
which is Hong Kong is where I'm from,
they issued a recommendation
for students to return.
And in the end, because
of personal reasons,
I actually did have to
physically relocate.
So, I was quite stubborn,
I was quite keen to save
as much of the original topic as I could.
And when I realized that
archives in Hong Kong and the UK
were closed, and that
the digitized resources
weren't exactly what I needed,
I pretty much had to
abandon that objective.
I still wanted to evaluate
Destination Tyneside,
and this was when I looked up ETHoS,
which is a database compiling
the doctoral projects
by different researchers in the UK.
So, on ETHoS I found a project
that had recently been
completed only in 2019
and had amazing field notes
about Destination Tyneside.
So, I actually managed to find
the researcher on LinkedIn
and we connected, and she
just so kindly provided
not just her field notes,
but images, and even
transcripts of the videos
that were being used in the display.
Through email, I also
spoke with the curator
of Destination Tyneside
and she not only had press images for me,
she even physically went
down to the gallery for me
to take photos, which was just brilliant.
I also had family and colleagues
who kindly offered to visit on my behalf,
but the main problem for that
was that there was no projected
reopening dates at all
for museums or archives in the UK.
I was still keen to
speak to Chinese people
and how they felt about the gallery.
I tried to do this over Zoom,
but one thing that became apparent
was the age of my target group.
I was looking at a wave of migration
that was triggered by the
UK colonial government
in Hong Kong in 60s,
encouraging rural populations
here to move over to the UK.
So, these people at their youngest
would have been at their 50s,
provided that they went over
there when they were children.
And the transition to online communication
has not been gentle for any of us,
but especially this target group
where people were I think the
oldest person I tried to reach
was nearing her 90s.
So, my physical location
meant that I couldn't physically
go up to talk to people,
and it became quite clear
that my initial strategy
to sort of mitigate my circumstances
didn't generate enough
data to support my project,
and I had to accept pretty much
that the topic wasn't going to work.
And in hindsight, I would disagree,
but in the moment there
was very much a feeling
that I had failed and it wasn't nice,
it wasn't nice at all.
So, I started looking at changing topics
and I think it's a recurring theme
amongst the fellow panelists
that we wanted to remain
in a similar ballpark for a topic
due to personal connection,
but also because we had
done the research already.
So, I basically took a
very erotic damage control
sort of approach where
identified the biggest problems
on my original topic and tried to fix it.
So, I widened my scope to
evaluate any displays of migration
in any part of the UK.
So, I stuck with Destination Tyneside,
but I also came across this
project called Arrivals,
which was a sort of public-led project
by a photographer,
just featuring different people
who had recently moved to
different parts of the UK.
So, not only did I have
the researcher's detailed field notes,
I also had the curators
photos from both projects.
I also started basically just
going through ancient websites
for hours and hours and
I found press previews,
which gave me a different
perspective on the gallery.
And then I went on even
TripAdvisor, Twitter,
and actually started
finding the public reviews
on these displays,
which was brilliant
because I had now
literally different angles
and perspectives of the galleries.
So, trends started to show
up and it became clear
that there was a chance
to talk about the methods
in displaying migration.
So I focused, especially on temporary
versus permanent displays
through objects or photographs as mediums.
I also wanted to talk to anyone
who was involved in displaying
migration in the UK.
And I was really fortunate to
be able to contact the curator
of Destination Tyneside
and the creator of the Arrivals project,
and we actually had brilliant interviews,
but it also meant that
apart from the varying
perspectives on the gallery,
I now had firsthand information
on what the expectations
the ideal project would have been.
Like I said, quite stubborn,
I still wanted to interview
any Chinese visitors
who saw these displays,
and it was really challenging
because of lockdown
on both sides, and the time
difference between the regions,
which was sometimes seven
hours or eight hours.
And I mentioned briefly the
age of the target group,
but soon enough occupation came into play,
the UK government rolled out a scheme
called Eat Out to Help Out,
which is this scheme to sort
of stimulate the economy
by reopening eateries.
And the people that I was looking
at and wanted to work with
were still heavily
involved in catering, FNB,
the important export of food,
or even just running supermarkets.
So, not only did I have
a low participation rate,
I actually had a higher withdrawal rate
where people wanted to help out,
but understandably had to
focus on their businesses
and were just so busy.
I still try to reach out
through various Chinese
Associations in the UK,
which some of you might
know as Tongxiang Hui.
I ended up speaking to a very small number
of participants at the end,
but not only did they have
a wealth of information
about themselves,
it turns out that they had
actually talked among themselves
and several people had information
that they felt would be really
important for me to know.
And I really, really
felt so grateful for that
because they absolutely did not
have to, they really didn't.
And while this did not
become a core objective
in my final topic, it
was actually so crucial
in the discussion of the project findings,
and it was actually sort of
mentioned in the feedback
of my project as well.
So for my final topic,
I, as you know, evaluated
the museum representations
of the Chinese diasporas in Britain.
So firstly, I looked at the expectations,
what the curators wanted
out of the project
through the interviews.
Then I looked at what happened in reality,
where I looked at my one field visit,
the different transcripts,
the different images,
and the different perspectives
of what the gallery
actually felt like.
And I was really lucky
that with the images,
it turns out they were
taken between 2013 to 2020.
So, I had an additional
layer where I could talk
about how a gallery ages
through seven years.
And finally, I had a
comparative discussion
of how the Chinese diasporas in Britain
were actually displayed.
And this was supported by
members of the Chinese community
in Britain and their
views on how they felt
when seeing displays
literally about themselves.
Changing topics is a really
difficult and personal decision,
especially when it's a topic
that's deeply connected
to your background,
and we always feel attached to our topics.
So, no matter how out of control
the circumstances might be,
there's always negative feelings
when something doesn't work out.
And another thing that I sort
of misunderstood in my process
of pivoting was that it was clean cut,
that if A doesn't work out,
you're just gonna jump straight to B,
but it wasn't like that
for me, it was messy,
it was erratic, gradual,
and it was so emotionally challenging.
So just to recap the resources I used,
ETHoS is a database of doctoral projects,
which sometimes even includes the data
that the researchers worked
with, which is brilliant.
I engaged some more unique sources
like there's a directory of
Chinese Associations in the UK
where you could basically see which person
you could contact for
press-related research matters.
There's not expectation that institutions
or individuals should help you,
but I've learned that it
doesn't hurt to contact them.
And I've been fortunate that
they have helped me a lot,
but I think it needs to
come with an understanding
of your target group.
And like I said,
for the clarity of my presentation
I've admitted the names,
but it really took a village
for this project to come together,
and I have all these people to thank,
down to even my sibling
who eventually visited the gallery for me.
So, I hope that my experience,
I've have been able to offer
some advice and resources,
but I also hope that
I've been able to offer
nothing if just emotional solidarity.
Thank you very much.
- Great, thank you so much, Tullia.
So, we are going to
reconvene for the Q&A now.
If people have questions,
please feel free to use the Q&A button
at the bottom of your screen.
I'd also like to invite
all of our panelists
to turn their video back on.
So, I actually just wanted to start off
with a question of my own
before we get into the questions
that have already been
put in the Q&A function.
And my question has to do
with what the kind of broader
implications of these research challenges
are for what the future of
China studies might look like,
and I'm thinking both
temporarily and geographically.
So, Yi Ci and Bill both mentioned
that you were originally
thinking of doing a project
more focused on the PRC,
but both of you ended
up moving back in time
to the late 19th or early 20th century.
And so my first question is
do you think it's possible
to study the PRC right now?
And if so, how would
you go about doing that?
And then my second question has to do
with just kind of the
geographical boundaries
of thinking about China itself,
Ching Kwan Lee has talked about
the specter of global China,
so is it do you think perhaps the time
to start thinking beyond the
bounds of the nation state
and to think about China in more global,
or transnational, or
diasphoric dimensions?
And again, you know, thinking concretely,
how do we go about doing that?
So, those are kind of two
but related questions,
one on the temporal dimension,
one on the geographical dimension.
And I just invite all of you to go ahead
and give your thoughts
since you are still kind of
in the thick of doing research
or have recently emerged
from writing your dissertations or theses.
So, why don't you go ahead,
and anyone can just jump in.
- I can take a stab at
the second question.
I definitely agree that you
don't need to be studying
geographically what we call China
to be studying Chinese history.
In my own experience,
I've found that it was
honestly a lot more informative
for me to look at what was going on
in the Chinese communities in the US,
and see it as a reflection
of what was also going on
in China during that time,
particularly around different campaigns
for different political
parties, different governments.
It's not like just when
they came to the US
those political struggles stopped,
especially with the pretty
dark history of like the US
treatment towards Chinese immigrants,
there was a very strong community
and political organizing spirit
amongst them that sought
to not only influence
their US kind of new home,
but also events back in China.
- You mentioned me in the first question,
so I can at least try taking a
stab at the first part of it,
you know, is it possible
to study the PRC today?
I mean, it depends on what
you wanna look at, you know?
It was not possible for me
to study some of the things
that I wanted to study
from the perspective
that I wanted to study them.
I did not stop my
dissertation in 1979 though,
because I ran out of material.
It would have been very easy,
and in fact, I plan to
continue for my book project
to go further, I kind of stopped it there
because that's where so much
work had already been done,
so I kind of wanted to
focus on what I was doing,
but there was a plethora of materials,
you know, in Chinese
and Iranian newspapers
talking about minor events
that aren't normally analyzed,
you know, what I call,
I like to look at what I
call like the combination
of official and unofficial
relations, so looking at both,
you know, kind of cultural and
social connections in tandem
with high-level political relations.
And that, I mean, there's
plenty more to be done
just from the same
methods I've been using,
looking at newspapers, memoirs, travelogs.
There's a great travelog
that I'm dying to dig into
from a very popular,
prominent Iranian author,
who went to China in the
1980s and kind of witnessed,
you know, this sort of early changes
that were going on in that
period and writes about them.
So I'm really fast,
you know, there's a
lot to be done I think,
especially if you're
interested in perspective
of the outside world on China and the PRC,
and there's a lot of
unexploited sources out there
for that kind of stuff.
- I think I wanna address the question
on whether it's possible
to study the PRC and how.
And I think I wanna say
it's very difficult,
but I wanna say that
there are possibilities
for doing for studying the PRC.
I think Emily and I,
when we talked about me switching topics,
I did say that we are at
the beginning of a great,
of a great flood of dissertations
about Republican China
because it is just easier
to get those sources.
But I also feel having gone
through this experience
and looking at what's out there
and looking at the
possibilities of working
with what's out there,
that I'm not going to abandon the PRC,
and I'm not going to abandon
like blood banking in Mao's China.
I do think there's a possibility
for looking at those,
looking at the PRC with what is published.
With blood banking for instance,
one of the people who are...
One of the foreigners who
were valorized in the PRC
was Norman Bethune,
and the idea of how he had
served China as a doctor.
And one of the things,
one of the tails that's told
about him is blood donation.
So, because this is part
of like the government propaganda, right?
This is accessible material
that would be kept in a
collection at Hoover for instance,
that kind of thing.
So, I do think there
are inroads to the PRC,
you just have to kind of what really hard,
it's probably harder than
it was five years ago,
but there are possibilities
out there I think.
Yeah.
- I also wanna mention,
I'm sure probably a lot
of people know this,
but there are a lot of Chinese
Foreign Ministry Archive
documents available online,
some of them are even conveniently
translated into English.
I don't know if one of
you guys can remember,
I'm blanking on the website
that I think it's through
the Hoover Institute though,
but there are documents that
were kind of taken or scanned
out of Foreign Ministry Archives
before they closed down,
and they are a lifeline to researchers
trying to piece together
what's going on right now.
- And the Wilson Center as well.
- That was it, the Wilson Center.
- Yeah.
- That's what I was thinking
of, thank you.
But yeah, they're a great
source for stuff like that
and is growing all the time.
- Maybe I can also chime in on
the question of PRC history.
My name is Denise Ho,
and I teach Modern
Chinese History at Yale,
I'm one of the co-organizers
of this series.
I think maybe, or the
way I would think about
the first part of Emily's question
is like with a metaphor
and then with looking at other fields.
So, the metaphor is just thinking about
like the number of pixels on a screen.
And I think when people look back
and then are nostalgic
at kind of a golden age
of research in Chinese history,
maybe that in the 90s and the early 00s,
I think people are get very excited
about what they were able to find.
And that the truth
is that we're just not in
that situation anymore.
So, I think that the people on this panel
have pointed to many of the different ways
in which you can still get
enough pixels to make a picture
so that you can still see an image
that describes something that is a real
and true story of Chinese history.
It might not have the
same grain of detail,
or it might require shifting
someone used the metaphor of
the aperture shifting focus,
but I think it's still possible,
and I certainly hope it's still possible.
And the second thing
that I think is useful
to think about is the way the
social scientists before us
did histories of the PRC,
but they were doing
field work with emigres
maybe in sort of taking out
some of the methodologies
that Tullia was describing,
or looking at newspapers.
So, I think this is done,
that this is not completely
unprecedented for us,
and so we should take inspiration
from many of these different fields.
- Yeah, that's great
insights from all of you.
And again, I mean, I'd also
just like to offer encouragement
in the sense that there have
been so many more sources
that have been digitized recently,
and that are typically accessible
through university
databases like newspapers
like Renmin Ribao,
or databases like Dousho,
all of these things,
I mean, a lot of these
sources are kind of mediated
in a particular way,
but all sources are mediated
and there are ways of
still working with them
and developing a fruitful topic.
So, I'll turn to one of the questions
that was asked in the Q&A,
this comes from Lu Hwang who asks
that about the issue of trying to strike
a good balance on taking a
wide view versus a deep dive
into a specific topic,
Lu working on Indian and
Tibetan Buddhist philosophy,
as well as Chinese Buddhist history,
they're trying to figure out a topic
that can both address their
broad research interests,
but not be too broad to be superficial.
And so, do you have any
insights about how to strike
a good balance between
adopting kind of a broad view,
but also being able to
get into the nitty gritty
of the detail of Chinese
history or Chinese philosophy
that we're all really passionate about?
- I can go ahead and start
just 'cause I talked a lot
about broad topics, right?
I think that like it's obviously
you don't wanna go too far
in the opposite direction,
you don't want something that's too broad,
you don't wanna try to
answer an entire field.
You know, one thing I was blessed with
was the fact that my field is wide open,
so I kind of decide what it was,
you know, not many people have really done
Sino-Iranian history
in this period before.
But, you know, the approach that I took
was really it's not like
I didn't do deep dives,
it's really more that I kind
of broadened my perspective
and did several deep dives
on different periods history
and kind of put that
together into a narrative.
You know, so like my early
chapter is on a very brief,
you know, 1905-1911 moment,
where Iranian and Chinese
constitutionalists are
talking to one another.
My second chapter is on the
1920s to the early 1940s,
you know, my third chapter
takes a chunk of 1949 to 1959.
And then the fourth chapter,
I do it that deep dive into Iranian Maoism
that I wanted to do.
You know, so I would say that
when you're thinking broadly,
you just kind of wanna think
about what you can do more
rather than like how can I?
You know, you don't wanna be
up in the stratosphere, right?
You wanna have something in
each chapter grounding you
to something more specific.
That's the best advice that
I think I could give on that.
- Does anyone else wanna
weigh in on that question?
- I'll just say I also think your advisor
plays a really important role in this.
I was very fortunate that my advisor and I
had a great communication system set up,
constantly on WeChat
chatting with each other.
And at times he was just
kind of brutally honest
if I was straying from my question
and really trying to keep me pinned
on what I was actually trying to research,
and not kind of squirreling
off in different directions,
which are personally interesting to me,
but at the end of the day,
I needed to write a cohesive document
that that would pass defense.
- So, I see that we're
actually getting some links
in the chat about other types
of sources or databases.
We kept the chat open specifically
so that people can share
their advice and their
resources with others,
but just when you do so,
remember to hit the button that says
send chat to panelists and attendees
because otherwise it will
just come to the panelists
and the attendees won't see it.
But if you have resources, or databases
or, you know, libraries,
or any type of online material
that you think might be
interesting for others to see,
please feel free to drop it in the chat,
we can also try to compile those
and send those out in a follow-up email
to all of the registered participants.
So, we got another
question from a librarian
asking about from your perspective
how librarians can make the best use
of their limited resources
and limited staffing,
so what would you particularly like to see
librarians do during this time
to try to serve as many
people as possible,
even with the types of funding
and staffing constraints
that they might be facing?
What would have been helpful for you
in the process of your research?
- I could take a stab at that.
I am coming from this as
someone who's in museums,
so I can sort of relate quite intimately
with the issues of funding,
or rather the lack thereof.
And I do agree that there
is a continuing demand
for more digitization to be done.
And in my research project,
I would have loved to have,
for example, shipping logs
or immigration records,
that would have been
really, really helpful,
but at the same time,
having worked in museums
during a pandemic actually,
I understand also it's
really, really difficult.
And that funding often
relies on external sources,
like especially in the UK,
which is a system I'm more familiar with.
So, there are a number of documents
that I would have loved to have had,
or maybe even just maybe
like a sort of directory
of the sources that
would have been available
as opposed to actual
scans of the resources.
That being said, I think
there is an element
of understanding that needs to be had
between researchers as well as people
who provide access to research,
that it is a difficult time for all of us,
that especially with libraries,
museums, and archives,
funding's getting smaller.
There's more dispute politically
about how to for example,
just make, for example,
colonial documents available.
So, I think that there is
an element of understanding
to be had here that we
need to be kind pretty much
and be okay that some documents
just won't be available to
us digitally for awhile.
- I can also just jump
in and say that recently
I've been fairly frustrated
about not being able to go
to archives or libraries,
even just in the region
of Southern California.
And what I've started doing
is reaching out personally
to archivists telling them
what my research interests are,
identifying particular databases
or sources that I'm interested in seeing.
And like 9 times out of 10,
I will get a response from the archivist,
and they've been really wonderful
about scanning these materials
and emailing them to me,
which is fantastic.
It doesn't hurt to ask, you
might not get a response,
you might not be able to
acquire all of the materials
that you're interested in,
but it is certainly
going to be more fruitful
than if you'd just don't ask at all,
so why not send an email?
Denise did you wanna jump in as well?
- I just wanted to throw out
a couple of other resources out there.
The Librarian for Digital Projects
at the Fairbank Center
at Harvard University,
who's been a supporter of this program.
Kwok-Leong Tang is organizing,
has been organizing a series of Q&A
like open office hours
where a group of librarians
actually get together
to answer questions.
So, I think that is a
really great resource.
I know that some history departments,
the Nanjing Technological
University History Department
has like crowdsourced a
spreadsheet of digital sources,
so I think there's a
lot of stuff out there
and just as many platforms
or not sharing knowledge
about what platforms
are out there for extra
lists of digitized sources
would be very helpful.
I think in some cases
there's a concern about
well, we can't publicly
share archives for example
because of the rules
that we have to adhere
to when we were originally
looking at those are archival materials.
But for published
sources, I think certainly
there are a lot of resources out there.
I wonder if I can ask the
panelists a question about
how you're...
Maybe from the point
of view of the advisors
and the departments, in what ways
where are your advisors
or departments helpful
in the process of the research pivot?
And in what ways could they
have offered more support?
- I could go first, mainly
because I had, as I said,
quite a messy sort of transition
process between my topics.
The thing I was most grateful
for was just the amount
of patience that my advisors had for me.
And a lot of advisors
are brilliant in that way
in just offering emotional support
and basically letting you
just sound ideas off them
again and again, and again,
until something works out.
And I think I struggled sort of asking
for more from my advisors
when considering that I
did my topic in a pandemic,
that being said, I think,
you know, it would have been
nice to be able to connect
with maybe even more subject specialists
or if I could be referred to other people
who might know be more well-versed
in the topic that I knew,
but it feels like I'm complaining
in what was a really bad situation.
So yeah, in the course
of doing a dissertation
in the pandemic the
thing I was most grateful
for was actually just the
support and the patience.
And I ended up finding, as I mentioned,
a lot of people externally who helped me.
So, the only sort of gripe that I had,
I've been able to solve
by approaching individuals myself as well.
- Yeah, I mean, I also
am very, very thankful
for my advisor, he was fantastic,
but I think something which is
more on the departmental side
is just flexibility in terms
of some of the more nitpicky
regulations that govern
whether it's defense
or how to kind of properly present things.
Speaking from personal experience,
a lot of those hadn't been updated
a year and a half into the pandemic.
So, when it came time for defense,
there was a lot of scrambling to be done
because there wasn't consideration
that we would be doing it online,
or digitally, or all of that.
And so I think just I wish I had known
kind of at the beginning
what that might entail,
but also at the departmental level,
just really thinking
through the different stages
that your students are going through,
and trying to build the
infrastructure for them to succeed.
- Okay, I should disclose
that one of my advisors is on this,
is one of the co-organizers
of this webinar (laughs).
So, I mean, I definitely I mean,
I agree that, you know,
talking with your advisors
is one of the things you have to do
when you decide you're going
to severely veer off the topic
that you proposed to do
for your dissertation.
And I, you know,
my advisors were very
supportive when I told them
about the difficulties I was facing.
I said, "Look, I tried and then
this is what happened to me,
but these are the new sources I found,
and this is something that
I think I can work with."
And it was a difficult conversation
because I had to deal with
like kind of the disappointment
of not doing the original topic,
but also talking to them
about something completely new
that I had not done before that point.
But, you know, they were very supportive
and I think I got great
feedback on the topic,
and especially when I was
writing the early chapters
to get comments on how it was shaping up
was really, really crucial for me
because for me, I was like being,
I was suddenly embarking on a new topic,
it wasn't a topic that I
had been thinking about
for like years, so that
was really, really scary.
And to have that kind of support
and that kind of feedback
at that formative stage
for my project was essential,
I think I wouldn't be
so close to the end now
if I didn't have that support.
And in terms of my department,
I think actually I've really been thankful
for how the department
has been supporting me
in terms of understanding
that grad students
would be like just
scattered around the world
and having to do everything digitally.
So, I think that I've been
very lucky with my department
that I've been supported kind
of administratively that way
as somebody who couldn't go back to the US
and then I'm just completing
from overseas now.
So, yeah.
- Great.
Well, I think we are
just about out of time,
right at 75 minutes,
so I would like to once again
thank our wonderful panelists
for providing their
experiences and insights.
I'd like to thank the Council
on East Asian Studies at Yale,
especially Stephanie Kim and Richard Sosa,
who provided all the staffing
and support for this event.
And of course, I would like to thank
all of you for attending.
Our next webinar in this
series will be on Monday,
July 19th at 7:30 PM Eastern.
It will be on the topic
of Archives, Libraries
and Databases in Taiwan.
Please note that you
will have to re-register
for that webinar in order
to receive the link,
it is not the same link
as the one that we used for this webinar.
You can go to the Yale Council
on East Asian Studies page
that Denise has just dropped in the chat,
and you can re-register for that.
Also, just as a heads up the next webinar
will at least partly be in Chinese
because we'll be hosting
several archivists
and librarians from Taiwan,
so just as a word of warning
you will need to speak
a little bit of Chinese
in order to understand.
But thank you again for tuning in,
and hopefully we will see you all again
in a couple of weeks.
So, take care.